Ray Kurzweil has argued that we're on
our way to a singularity that is that if
you look at the change and the
interaction of scientific fields over
the course of the last century or so and
you project it forward what you see is
not a linear progression but an
exponential progression which means that
as things change they're going to change
more rapidly so that the curve will mean
that over a very short period of time we
will make giant leaps in scientific
sophistication what he's argued about
that is that that is going to reach the
kind of critical mass which will mean
that at some point and there are
different dates that have been projected
but it's not that far in the future
couple decades we are going to be able
to so manipulate human form and function
so change the nature of life that it's
impossible on this side of that moment
that he calls a singularity to predict
what life will be like on the other side
of that singularity I happen to think
he's wrong I think that things will
change I think things will change
dramatically but I don't think that
moments going to come anything like in
the way that he thinks it's going to
come societies are too complex for that
our interactions with different
scientific fields look one of the things
that we have found out over and over and
over again in when we talk about biology
and biotechnology is that things are
much more complex than we think they are
first we were going to decode the human
genome and that was going to open up
everything we needed to know about the
nature of life and then we said oh no we
just finished the human genome but we
don't really understand the proteins
that these genome that disease genes
code for so we have to map the proteome
and we have to get all of these proteins
together and then people said oh no
that's not going to be enough because
now we've kind of discovered epigenetics
and we realize that the the genome is
mediated by all kinds of cellular
mechanisms that decide what gets
expressed and how it gets expressed and
what and that's how things go
the same things happen in the brain
sciences where a lot of our assumptions
about the way the brain work and
synaptic relationships and and mid-level
brain organization turned out to be much
more simplistic than we thought it was
and we still don't really understand how
the brain works and I think what we're
going to find over time is that rather
than convergence leading us to some sort
of unified idea is that there will
constantly be this kind of complexity
fall out as we learn about things deep
more deeply and and and more deeply we
will discover that in fact there's all
kinds of peripheral work to be done that
we couldn't even imagine looking forward
and what that means is you're not going
to have a convergence towards a
singularity but you're going to have a
very complex set of guide of moments
where things will change in a lot of
different ways and I think these things
singularity is actually a very
simplistic idea and it misunderstands
the complex nature of biological life
and physical life and you know physics
also thought it was going to find its
grand unified theory a long time ago and
now we were just beginning to discover
that maybe the universe isn't exactly
organized the way we thought it was with
dark matter and string theory and all of
that which we still don't really
understand the nature of them we can't
agree about so I'm not a big singularity
fan I think that reycarts wilds basic
insight that science is increasing and
that in a very rapid rate more rapidly
than people recognize and that there is
a convergence of fields the classic
nineteenth-century fields of biology and
chemistry they don't they don't make any
sense anymore
everything is interdisciplinary
universities have to change their
structure now because we're still I've
spent my life in universities and we're
still functioning on a 19th century
model of what a university should be
with these departments that have somehow
gotten so petrified in their place that
we are petrified of changing them but I
also think that part of the
the nature of understanding that moved
towards complexity is recognizing that
even as we get more and more
sophisticated about it
part of that sophistication will be
discovering new complex phenomenon that
right now we can't even imagine exists
and that's suggesting that it's all
going to be tied up in a moment where
we're just going to understand
everything well enough to transform the
world is I think a fairly naive and
simplistic view of how things are going
to change